y este viernes en revista de prensa nos
acompaña nuestra periodista Marta Moya
Marta bienvenida y buenos días para
usted Feliz viernes María Clara feliz
viernes empecemos por una noticia Y es
que el diario estadounidense de New York
Times está reportando algo que ya había
dicho la Comisión Interamericana de
Derechos Humanos pero ahora lo están
mostrando con evidencia Y es que las
fuerzas armadas de Perú tuvieron una
reacción desproporcionada contra los
manifestantes antigubernamentales Así es
María Clara y Esta es una investigación
visual que hace el New York Times que
recopila y analiza cientos de vídeos de
material en audio revisa informes de
autopsias informes balísticos y habla
con testigos y expertos para concluir
que efectivamente las fuerzas de
seguridad peruanas utilizaron la fuerza
letal para reprimir a los manifestantes
en estas protestas que como sabemos
empezaron a bueno en diciembre después
de que Pedro Castillo el expresidente
intentará dar un autogolpe intentar
disolver el congreso y gobernar por
decreto no lo consiguió fue detenido
entró como primera mandataria Dina
boluarte y al final pues se
desarrollaron unas protestas que todavía
están en curso con mayor o menor
intensidad pero en el sur del país donde
el expresidente tenía sus mayores apoyos
todavía Pues hay estos choques entre
manifestantes y las fuerzas policiales y
el New York Times hace una recopilación
de cómo utilizaron esa fuerza letal con
incluso rifles de asalto y matando a
manifestantes a corta distancia y lo
propongo que hagamos una revisión Por
alguno de esos casos y empecemos por
ayacucho con la muerte de dos civiles sí
María Clara vamos a ver cómo el York
Times se reporta la muerte de
Christopher Ramos un joven de 15 años y
de José Luis Aguilar un chico de 20 años
nos retrotraemos al 15 de diciembre
luego de que Dina boluarte decretara el
estado de emergencia quedó las fuerzas
de seguridad de mayores poderes entonces
la policía llega a despejar el
aeropuerto local y alrededor de las dos
de la tarde según reporta el New York
Times la policía empieza a lanzar gases
lacrimógenos contra los manifestantes
que responden con piedras según un
registro militar sostiene este medio 80
soldados entonces recibieron fusiles
galile utilizados también por las
defensas israelíes y empiezan a utilizar
esas armas contra los manifestantes de
manera totalmente indiscriminada Ya por
la tarde una de esas balas alcanza a
Christopher recordemos de 15 años y
según el informe de balística le
atraviesa todo el torso y sale La bala
por el otro hombro después minutos más
tarde una de esas balas alcanza a José
Luis Aguilar que también cae víctima de
una bala en la cabeza armamento de
guerra entonces Marta para reprimir a
los manifestantes y ahora quiero que
hablemos de juliaca porque y fue la que
ha sido la protesta más mortífera desde
que comenzaron las manifestaciones en
diciembre y esta protesta en juliaca
dejó 18 muertos qué dice el New York
Times al respecto sí María Clara de 18
muertos 70 heridos al menos 31 de ellos
por disparos entonces la respuesta de
los agentes fue desalojar también el
aeropuerto local y se atribuye la
mayoría de muertes y heridos con
lesiones por bala por la tarde el
enfrentamiento se recrudece entre los
policías y los civiles que responden
también con piedras y la policía empieza
a lanzar gases lacrimógenos primero
desde el suelo y después desde
helicópteros a Baja distancia
posteriormente los agentes empiezan a
disparar armas de fuego y el New York
Times reporta que se habrían utilizado
fusiles de asalto kalashnikov por encima
de la cintura a una distancia de menos
de 65 pies lo que es una distancia
totalmente letal para los manifestantes
los disparos continúan a lo largo de la
noche con en dirección a los
manifestantes y se analiza pues como
decíamos que habrían utilizado
calashnikov todos los civiles que
murieron ese día que es el 9 de enero
todos resultaron heridos y resultaron
por heridas de bala todos en la parte
superior y cuatro en la cabeza
impresionante Marta y qué pasó en la
región de macusani Pues sí también nos
retrotraemos al 18 de enero dos civiles
entonces una madre soltera de 35 años y
un joven camionero de 30 años fueron
asesinados también por disparos
atribuidos entonces a la Policía
Nacional según la evidencia visual los
audios y los relatos de los Testigos era
una marcha pacífica que al final se
empezó a recrudecer también en New York
Times dice que entonces se utilizaron
rifles de asalto calashnikov y se ve
como un policía dispara con ese callas
nikov desde la oficina y al final se
escuchan sucesivas ráfagas
esta mujer muere por disparo en la
cabeza y ya llega muerta al hospital y
el hombre camionero de 30 años muere por
un disparo en el pecho al día siguiente
Marta le propongo que cambiemos
totalmente de tema y nos vayamos algo
más amable porque la revista Time
publicó una lista de los 50 destinos que
vale la pena visitar en este 2023 y
dentro de estos está una ciudad que Para
ustedes muy especial Pues sí María Clara
y una que para ti también lo es porque
Barcelona y Medellín están en la lista
de los 50 destinos que la revista Time
propone visitar este 2023 Ahora solo hay
que tener el dinero para ello entre
ellos pues hay destinos en los cinco
continentes nos propone el Time viajar a
Ruanda para hacer un trekking con
gorilas a Honduras para visitar un coral
de arrecife también nos propone ir a
Nápoles para disfrutar de la gastronomía
italiana o Arizona para visitar el
Desierto de Sonora además al final de
este artículo nos dan un par de Consejos
sobre Cómo ahorrar dinero en los vuelos
y diferentes estrategias para reservar
habitaciones de hotel baratas Bueno un
consejo bastante necesario sobre todo si
queremos visitar varias de estas
ciudades Marta Gracias por revista de
prensa y todo lo que nos trajo hoy
Gracias María claro